sono ancora fortissimo
[Musica]
aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto sono stata
rinchiusa nella prigione dal lupo
cattivo
devo riuscire a scappare da
questa volta
credo che abbia detto che vuole
mangiarmi Ma come faccio a scappare da
qua Aspetta un momento però
perché ti sei vestito così da nonnetta
il lupo si è vestito da donna
[Risate]
[Musica]
giro e in effetti potrebbe essere che
l'hai mangiata la nonna come il
Cappuccetto rosso è per questo che mi
hai dato il vestito da Cappuccetto Rosso
vero
credo proprio che vogliamo mangiarmi ma
come faccio adesso a scappare L'unico
che può salvarmi è vitale Ma dove si
Sarà cacciato lasciate un mi piace se
volete che riesco a scappare da questo
Escape Room per non essere mangiato dal
lupo cliccate mi faccia qua sotto Vitale
dove sei vitale sono Chiesa in prigione
che buoni questi biscotti Ciao Guerrino
che cosa c'è
mi vuoi dire qualcosa
Ma no tu vuoi questi E io non te li
posso dare questi sono dolci mi fanno
male i denti non ti preoccupare non li
mangio io però
che cosa Merlino
da quella parte
ti devo seguire da quella parte
ma Merlino mi vuole dire qualcosa mi ha
chiesto di seguirlo
devo aprire questa porta
sembra che mi stia indicando di aprire
questa porta
[Musica]
Vitale
No aiuto
aiuto
Cosa ti è successo
Ok Io non ho visto niente
sognando è tutto ok
[Musica]
Oh no Anita è stata imprigionata dal
lupo
ma come posso fare adesso per aiutarla
Ma certo posso chiamare il nostro amico
lupox Lui sì che mi saprà aiutare e
riusciremo insieme a debellare Anita Sì
Allora apri il libro Gira due volte
Chiudi il libro e lui apparirà
tutto a posto Ciao Vitale Ma che succede
c'è un problema Alice è stato
imprigionata dal lupo cattivo e ho
bisogno del tuo aiuto per liberarla Oh
no ha manifestato imprigionata Eh sì Da
chi Da un lupo è un lupo cattivo non
sono sicuro che sia un lupo mannaro ma
sicuramente un lupo cattivo Ma lo sai
benissimo che ho paura dei lupi mannari
Io non ti posso aiutare e dai l'ex
Almeno dimmi come posso fare a liberarla
alla fine ti sto chiedendo solo un
consiglio Ok allora puoi provare questa
soluzione che soluzione che soluzione
bevi la pozione per trasformarti in un
lupo mannaro e poi potrai affrontarlo Ah
la pozione che ho creato qualche giorno
fa Va bene proverò così allora Grazie
comunque Alexa alla prossima Grazie Ti
auguro un in bocca al lupo ma come in
bocca al lupo scusa Ah volevo dire Buona
fortuna Grazie l'ex Ciao ci vediamo Ciao
l'ex Grazie mille per il tuo aiuto Ok
adesso che so quello Che devo fare Vado
a preparare la pozione così la berrò che
potrò liberare Anita dalla prigione
andiamo
[Musica]
quel Pippone di vitale è scappato
quindi non potrà salvarmi
Ehi lupo ma tu vuoi mangiarmi
vuoi mangiarmi come Cappuccetto Rosso
Dai ti prego Non mangiarmi se mi fai
uscire da qua Ti prometto che ti
cucinerò qualcosa di buono
ma
[Musica]
uffa Ma perché vuoi mangiare proprio me
ah ah
Non ho capito
uno
Sì due due
laggiù
Oh no
[Musica]
ha rinchiuso anche Merlino in prigione
Ma perché cosa c'entra lui
[Musica]
cosa
Non ho capito lupo hai detto Merlino e
poi fuori e poi cosa vuoi dire
niente
[Musica]
tu
mangiare
due
persone
ok
1 io
2 Cioè la seconda
[Musica]
volta ma che cosa c'entra Merlino
Poverino perché hai rinchiuso Merlino in
prigione
Giovanna
[Musica]
ho capito aiutato Merlino comesca Ma
possibile che evitare non faccia niente
per aiutarci
[Musica]
Ok adesso è pronta è perfetta è proprio
come quella che avevo fatto l'altra
volta non mi resta che berla e potrò
trasformarmi il lupo mannaro
[Musica]
Chissà se sta funzionando
mi sono spuntata le orecchie Sì sta
funzionando adesso posso andare a
salvare Anita preparati lupo avrai così
tanta paura che scapperai e ora vado
ah eccomi qua dopo mannaro adesso mi
sono trasformato e sono forte come te
Vitale
si è trasformato e adesso libererò la
vita
[Musica]
AH AH AH
AH AH
AH AH AH AH AH AH AH AH AH
sono ancora fortissimo
Vitale crede di essere forte ma non è
forte per niente
[Musica]
mi sa che non sono così fortissimo come
pensavo
aspetta aspetta aspetta
Ma possibile che non mi vedi Guardami Eh
c'ho delle bellissime orecchie dei
bellissimi peli e zampe sono proprio
come te Certo sono un pochettino più
bello di te però non lo capisci che
siamo uguali Siamo due lupi mannari
Guarda ho una bellissima coda anche E
dai facciamo la pace facciamo la pace eh
[Musica]
vedi sta funzionando
Ce ne hai messo a capirlo ne sono come
te
wow wow che cosa sta succedendo adesso
ma che cosa sta succedendo Che cosa stai
facendo la smetti di parlare
È un lupo mannaro Ma perché mi sta
andando
oh oh oh oh che cosa
sta un po' cattivo sta sbaciucchiando
Vitale basta Aspetta stai Un po'
esagerando adesso con tutte queste
affezioni Ah sì mi sono seduto Ok Che
cosa c'è
Ma che cosa sta succedendo perché mi sta
baciando le mani mi state facendo Non
capisco
Vedila voi due Ehi lupo cattivo Fammi
capitare già fidanzato con me capito
ma che cosa vuoi tu sei un lupo mannaro
No non sei un lupo mannaro
[Musica]
una Lupa Mannara ah ah ah
calma Calmati Calmati Adesso calmati
Vergognati Vergognati
non non respingerla Ok tu non
respingerla che cosa stai dicendo Beh
lei è innamorata di te e è innamorata di
te farà qualsiasi cosa tu voglia e
quindi mi darà tutto quello che voglio
da mangiare
al lupo cioè la lupa di liberarmi Ah
certo sì hai ragione ma sei un genio
Anita Certo certo Adesso farò finta di
essere Anch'io innamorato così potrà
liberarti Ok ok copincina Mi raccomando
Speriamo che funzioni
io volevo
dirti ho sempre sognato di avere una
fidanzata così pelosa volevo proprio
sempre sognato guarda sei proprio Sei
proprio bellissima
ma ascolta Eh Caro lupo Ti volevo
chiedere un favore faresti qualcosa per
me
sì faresti qualcosa per me Grazie grazie
grazie ti voglio tanto bene ti voglio ah
aiuto aiuto aiuto che sarà scolla questa
di rosso adesso
mi incazzo solo Uh un piccolo favore ma
non è che potresti liberare la mia
fidanzata
la mia carissima amica in Italy è così
noi possiamo scappare insieme da
fidanzati eh Che ne pensi la liberiamo
la liberi e poi magari io scappo e
scappiamo
Che bello forse l'ho convinta a liberare
Anita eh eh eh eh eh
un po' di più Inter attentato che
dovresti passare qui per spaccare tutto
quel progetto Eh vabbè vabbè Vai vai un
bacetto quello bacetto ok E ti do il
progetto
[Musica]
sulla guancia
Ah ah ah la sua vita Sbrigati sta
funzionando sta funzionando il nostro
piano ha funzionato stava aprendo la
porta della prigione Ah che c'è
[Musica]
una cosa
Un bacio
un bacio nella guancia da parte di
Vitale nuovamente
E vabbè Vitale dargli questo bacio nella
guancia così apre la porta
l'effetto della pozione è svanito
Speriamo che non se ne accorga
[Musica]
Perché non chiudi gli occhi quando ti dà
il bacio della guancia e tieni gli occhi
chiusi eh mi raccomando Non aprirli per
nessun motivo
chiudi gli occhi
[Musica]
sorridente
Aiuto aiuto
Ti sei fatto imprigionare
Hai visto Mi sono ritornato normale ma
adesso come facciamo a uscire da questa
prigione Bella domanda Non lo so Non c'è
nessuno che ci può salvare adesso
aspetta Ho un piano
Che ne pensi non è un'idea geniale
vero che funzioni però dai proviamo
una proposta da farti è come dire
conosciamo un lupo bellissimo Ciao un
occhio celeste un occhio color Ambra
Stupendo È bellissimo conosciamo un lupo
bellissimo Per te potrebbe diventare il
tuo fidanzato Sì ma come no sì non l'hai
neanche visto Aspetta ma che ritieni in
memoria È stupendo è davvero un nostro
amico carissimo
super bello è super bravo però ascolta
un attimino
Noi ti facciamo conoscere il nostro
amico il lupo lex e vedrai che ti
innamorerai perché è davvero un
bellissimo E come dice Tu ci liberi no
noi non possiamo chiamare come se non ci
liberi come facciamo ad uscire tu ci
liberi Noi lo chiamiamo e te lo facciamo
conoscere Che ne pensi
dai devi per forza liberarci se vuoi che
ti facciamo conoscere il nostro amico il
lupo ex
migliore amica che bello che bello che
bello ce l'abbiamo fatta E adesso per
favore se ci vuoi liberare
Dai dai dai Apriti per favore anche da
questa parte
cosa siamo liberi Finalmente anch'io
sono libero finalmente
avevo per un attimo avevo dimenticato
Dobbiamo chiamare il nostro amico lex
per presentartelo fartelo conoscere
possibilmente innamorarsi
Che bello Meno male abbiamo sempre una
copia del nostro libro con noi non credo
che piacerà molto all'ex questo piano ma
è l'unico piano per salvarci Allora come
raggiro due volte
abbiamo bisogno di nuovo nel
taglio
Eccolo eccolo
Quanto è bello
[Musica]
avevo detto te l'avevamo detto che era
un bel figo
c'hai ragione
[Musica]
Ma ma quello è un lupo mannaro e no è
una Lupa mannara
Oh perché mi sta guardando così credo
che si sia innamorata di te
innamorato di me no no no mi dispiace a
me piace un altro No no no
Ah ah ah
ah Che schifo ah ah aiuto
[Musica]
povero lex questa non ce la perdonerà mi
sa ma almeno abbiamo completato la
Challenge E ora vi lasciamo Qua quattro
caselline su cui cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quella
che preferite eh Buona visione Ciao